(upbeat music)
- So you live half the
time right here in Israel
and half the time in Florida.
So I don't know that
there's ever been a guest
that I'm supposed
to sit down with
in Jerusalem in this
exact spot more than you.
But I want to actually
start somewhere else
for just a minute or so,
because you also grew
up in Long Island,
like basically 10 minutes
from where I grew up from.
- That's right.
- And I thought for people
that don't know your bio,
could you give just
sort of a one-minute bio
that'll then get us
to to everything else
that you've done?
- Sure, son of a rabbi.
Thought about becoming a rabbi.
My father had a
1,000-member congregation.
He was a great rabbi.
When I told him I was
thinking of becoming a rabbi,
he cried.
He begged me not to do it.
- (laughs) I was gonna
say, tears of joy or-
- No, no, not tears of joy.
He was like, "Why would
you want to do that?"
- It's a tough gig.
- "Be a doctor or a lawyer,
make some money and
don't have 1,000 bosses
telling you what to do,"
even though he loved his job.
Sent me off to Columbia
University, became a lawyer.
Lived basically in the
area where I grew up
for most of my life,
until I became the U.S.
Ambassador to Israel
and moved here in 2017.
- Okay, so you probably
are the most influential
U.S. ambassador to Israel
probably in its existence,
I mean, I know...
Do you want to pat
yourself on the back?
Is that fair to say,
I mean?
- Well, put it this way.
"The New York Times" said
that, and they're no fans, so.
- (chuckles) Oh, so they
might have been sticking you
when they said that.
- Well, they said that,
so we'll refer to
them for that, yeah.
- So let's start
just with exactly where
we are at the moment,
and the incredible history and
geography of where we're at,
before we get into some of
the politics of the region
that you've really helped shape,
which has clearly led to an
incredibly flourishing Israel.
In my five days here, I can't
believe what's going on here.
- Yeah, yeah.
Well, look, we're about a
10-minute walk from my home,
and we are right here,
where that gold dome is,
is the holiest place
for the Jewish people.
It's now called the
Dome of the Rock.
It was built maybe
1500 years ago.
But 3,000 years ago, it's
where the Jewish Temple stood.
And that Temple stood
in two different forms,
but it stood for 1,000 years.
And it was destroyed the
second time in the year 70.
And ever since then, until 1967,
the Jewish people
have been praying,
in every country,
whether it's, you know,
north Africa, eastern
Europe, the United States,
for 2,000 years, Jews have
prayed to return to this land,
to return exactly to that spot.
And in 1967, right
after the Six-Day War
where Jerusalem was
reunified, it came to be.
So, you know, even though
this dome and this mosque
look very old, and they
are, relatively speaking,
they're pretty recent when
you think of Jewish history
that goes back 3500 years.
- Right, so it's hard for
people to imagine, but,
because everyone thinks
that the Western Wall
is actually the holiest
site in Judaism;
but it's the Temple
Mount that the mosque,
which is right there, and
then the Dome of the Rock,
are built on here.
And the Western Wall is
actually just a retaining wall.
- It's a retaining wall.
It's a lot bigger than
that; it goes much further.
If you go underground, you
can see it goes further.
But it's a retaining wall.
The holiest site in Judaism
is the Temple Mount.
It is under that, it's
called the Dome of the Rock
because the rock is the rock
on which Abraham was called
to sacrifice his son, Isaac,
and he passed the test that
was given to him by God,
and God promised
that he'd become
the father of many nations.
It all began there,
under that rock.
And then, of course,
that's where Solomon
built the first Temple.
It's enormously
important to Jews.
And the proof of it is that,
you know, for thousands of
years when we didn't have it,
we prayed for it.
Look, the other thing
is if, you know,
you see the mosque to the right,
the Aqsa Mosque is the
silver mosque, right.
- Right, that's this right here.
- So if you go into
the mosque and pray,
and you or I couldn't do that,
but if you went into
the mosque and prayed,
you would bow down and
you would face south,
you would face Mecca.
Your back would be
to the Temple, okay.
So the Temple is not,
even the holiness of
Jerusalem is very secondary
to the Muslim world, relative
to the holiness of Mecca.
You know, Jerusalem was
not mentioned in the Koran.
It's mentioned 699 times
in the Old Testament.
- And all that being said,
all the religions
are being respected.
You can see Muslim
worshipers, right?
- Yeah.
- Literally right there.
I don't know if they can
quite be seen by our camera.
And then plenty of, obviously,
of Jewish worshipers and
Christian worshipers.
- It's actually more than
them being respected.
Because, you know,
you see here straight
ahead is the Western Wall,
up on top is the mosque,
and to the left is the
Church of the Holy Sepulchre,
which is one of the holiest
sites in Christianity.
Now, if you're a Jew,
if you're a Muslim,
if you're a Christian,
if you're an atheist,
you can go to the Church
of the Holy Sepulchre,
you can go to the Western Wall.
If you want to go up on the
Temple Mount, all right,
and you're not a Muslim,
you have one access point,
which is this rickety gate
here called the Mughrabi Gate,
where you go through security.
There's 10 other
access for believers,
you know, whet they refer
to as believers here,
which are just Muslims.
And if you happen to
be a Jew or a Christian
and you go up through this
gate onto the Temple Mount
and you begin to pray,
you're escorted off the
mosque, off of the Mount.
- The U.N. will write up
a couple recommendations.
- So it's not equal access,
it's actually better access.
The state of Israel affords
better access to Muslims,
far better access to Muslims
than it does to
Christians and Jews.
And it's odd, because, you know,
it's referred to generally
as the status quo.
But if you look at the treaty
between Jordan and Israel,
the treaty says
that both nations,
regardless of sovereignty,
will afford complete and
equal and unfettered access
to every Abrahamic faith
as to every holy site.
And that's not done
here; it's not observed.
- Right, so it's sort of ironic,
and then we'll move on
to some other stuff,
that Israel is actually
affording more courtesies
than was happening
before, you know-
- Yeah.
- Israeli control, but.
- And Al-Aqsa has been
the theme since 1929,
when there was a
massacre in Hebron,
where hundreds of
Jews were killed.
The false claim that the
Jews are storming the mosque,
taking over the mosque,
it's always been kind
of the rallying point
whenever Arab
terrorists have sought
to create violence
against the Jewish people.
- All right, so let's,
I know we could do the
history clearly all day long,
for many days.
(Ambassador Friedman chuckles)
So let's get to the broader
Middle East, though.
- Sure.
- Because you were integral
in what has happened
here over these last now,
you know, seven years or so.
So talk to me about when
you became ambassador,
I mean, were you, was
that the immediate plan,
like, "We're gonna
do this stuff"?
Did it sort of fall in your lap,
and did you ever think
it was even possible?
- So, I was the first
ambassador appointed
in the Trump administration,
even before he took office.
And we put out a press release,
and I was quoted, with the
permission of the President,
with saying that I look
forward to serving my country
from an embassy in its
eternal, undivided capital,
Jerusalem, in Israel's
undivided capital.
So this was number
one on my agenda.
- Right, so that was
before the deals, even.
- That's before we
even took office.
- Yeah.
- We worked on it really hard.
We, in less than a year,
the President recognized
Jerusalem as the
capital of Israel.
And then, May 14th
of 2018, exactly five years
ago this coming May 14th,
which is also Israel's
Day of Independence,
we opened up our embassy.
And, you know, the
entire world predicted
that this would create endless
wars and untold violence,
and it really
didn't, not at all.
- No, there was
basically nothing.
- Basically nothing,
and you know why?
Because everybody who's
looked at this knows
that Jerusalem is the
eternal, undivided capital
of the Jewish people.
I mean, you have to know it.
If you, you read
the Bible, right?
The Bible sells more books on
Amazon than any other book.
Anybody who reads
the Bible knows
that Jerusalem belongs
to the Jewish people,
including most of
the Christian world,
so, and most of
the Muslim world.
And most of the Muslims
actually consider,
you know, Mecca to be
holy, far less Jerusalem.
So not surprisingly,
that's the least.
There was at that time-
- So did that embolden you guys?
Once that was done and settled,
and it didn't inflame the
world, did then you go,
"Okay, now we can
really do some"-
- It gave us a real
tailwind in two respects.
Number one, it
gave us the ability
to make more positive moves
that had been neglected for
years with regard to Israel.
So recognized Israel's
sovereignty over
the Golan Heights,
which was never
gonna leave Israel,
was never gonna be given back
to a butcher like Bashar Assad.
And then we started focusing
more on the Palestinians
and how to, you know,
maybe choreograph some
sort of a peace plan.
But what we found was, and I
think this is the key point,
people said, "You're gonna make,
you're gonna create violence
by supporting Israel and
supporting Jerusalem."
Just to the contrary.
I mean, we actually
created an environment of,
that was conducive
to peace. Why?
Because the Arab nations that
we made peace with, right,
they looked at our
relationship with Israel,
and said, you know, "We
want to get in on that.
You know, we want to be an
ally of the United States
the same way that
Israel's an ally.
How do we get there?
How do we get closer
to each other?"
And you know, in
many cases, we said,
"Well, the road to that
kind of relationship
has to run through Israel.
You have to normalize
with Israel.
You can't, you know,
be closer to America
when you're, you know,
shouting, 'Death to Israel'.
You're fighting our
most important ally,
maybe in the world, but
certainly in the Middle East."
And so, our closeness to
Israel was actually an asset
in our relationship
with the Arab world.
And it drew us closer to them.
And ultimately, you know, we
would sit with these countries,
it started off with the UAE,
and we said, "Look," you know,
and by the way, you know,
Trump said this on
his very first trip.
He went to Saudi Arabia, he
sat with 52 Muslim nations,
and he said something he
doesn't get credit for.
He said, "Look, this idea that
Israel's gonna be destroyed,
put it out of your mind.
Just forget about it.
It's a pipe dream; it's
never gonna happen.
And it's gonna keep
you at distant, at
arms length with us."
That's number one.
Number two, you know, "Radical
Islamic terrorism, okay,
it's your problem
first, not ours, okay.
You know, you stop it before
it crosses the Atlantic Ocean.
And if you do that, you
will find in America
a level of friendship you've
not experienced before."
So he actually set the tone,
you know, very
early in the term.
But we worked on that
theme throughout.
And as we got closer
to the end of the term,
we found these countries,
they saw a window closing.
"How can we, you know, align
ourselves with America,
you know, in a way that
starts to resemble, you know,
this alliance with Israel?
How can we build this, you know,
this kind of circle
of trust, you know,
around a common threat of Iran?"
And you know, it
involved, you know,
some you know, fabulous
discussions, negotiations,
and ultimately results.
- I don't know how much
you can say on this,
but how close were you?
I mean, there were
all the rumors
that there were gonna be all
these other rapprochements,
and obviously, you guys
literally just ran out of time.
And now, unfortunately,
our administration
is looking at the Middle
East very differently.
- Yeah, we would've
normalized with Saudi Arabia.
Saudi Arabia would've
normalized with Israel by now,
if we were still in.
It's a massive game changer.
I mean, you're
talking about now,
the leader of the Muslim world.
- Right.
- Normalizing this
relationship, it just changes,
it really ends, you know, ends,
just puts a period on the
Arab-Israeli conflict,
and it unites everyone
against radicalism.
You know, when I met
with the foreign
minister of the UAE,
about six months after
the Abraham Accords,
there had been a war in Gaza.
They're getting all their
news from Al Jazeera,
which is very
unfavorable to Israel.
I sat and I met with him
and I said to him,
"How are we doing?"
He said, "No, we're passing
with flying colors."
And he said to me,
"You know why?"
And what he said to me was,
"The wars of the 21st century,"
now this was before
Russia and Ukraine,
which may be the exception
that proves the rule.
But he says,
"The wars of the 21st
century are wars of ideology.
They're not wars
between nations anymore.
And the main ideological war
is extremism versus
the moderates.
And the moderates have to win.
And to us, the Abraham Accords
is all about the moderates
winning the war."
- When you were, when
the whole administration
was, you know,
packing their bags,
and then there's
incoming people,
did you have any communication
with the incoming people,
saying, "Hey guys," and I asked
Jared Kushner this as well,
"Hey, we're on the path here"?
Was there anything that
you could have done
that would've
continued everything?
And look, hopefully it'll
continue, maybe in two years.
- Yeah, well look, for the
first six months, it was,
anything Trump was,
you know, verboten.
You know, no, we're not gonna...
And then they
realized, you know,
the Abraham Accords
are so popular
among so many different
people, Democrats as well,
they began to embrace them.
But it's not about
embracing them
or paying lip service to it.
It's about being a
friend to Saudi Arabia.
Now look, Saudi Arabia
is an imperfect country.
There's no question about it.
And they have that one
incident, which is horrific.
But you know what?
You know, you know,
I'm not gonna quote
Jesus because I'm Jewish.
But you know,
"Whoever's without sin,
you know, come forward,"
you know, and you're not,
no one's coming forward.
Saudi Arabia could
be a very good friend
of the United States; they
have been in the past.
We could advance
that relationship.
And what Biden's done
really, has been to
really push 'em away.
And they're furious
with America right now,
as are some of the
other Gulf nations.
They don't see America standing
for moderate Sunni Islam
the way we promised we
would, and the way we should.
And so, you know, when you
think about the Abraham Accords,
you tend to think
of it as, you know,
bilateral relations
between Israel
and UAE, or Bahrain, or Morocco.
They're not; it's
a triangle, right?
Israel and an Arab
country are at the base,
and the U.S. is at the apex,
and U.S. plays the
most important role.
Everybody's looking to the U.S.
for what they can achieve
in that relationship.
We're the strongest
country in the world,
we're the most important
and everybody wants
to be close with us.
And as we push countries away,
we dilute the Abraham Accords.
- Right, and if it ain't
us, it's most likely China.
- It's China.
- And that's a very
different world.
- Could be, right, I mean, look,
Saudi's moving closer to
China, Russia, and Iran.
And that's not a
shot against Israel;
it's a shot against America.
That's a signal to America,
"Guys, you know,
this works both ways.
You want to push us away,
you know, we'll push
you away as well."
- I want to ask you
one other thing,
because when we got here,
I really didn't
know what to expect.
I was bringing my team, we were
gonna tour historical sites,
we were gonna talk
to people like you.
But what I'm realizing now,
just in five days in Jerusalem,
is that there is an
incredible strength here
despite the divisions,
despite the security stuff.
And, you know, you live
in the Promised Land,
and what I would say is the
other promised land of Florida.
(Ambassador Friedman laughs)
So what is that connection,
the freedom that's
happening in Florida,
the freedom and strength
that's happening here,
to me, that's what has to
be exported to save America.
Which, you know,
here in Jerusalem,
this is what every one
of our major cities,
and they're not gonna
look like geographically,
but the spirit of this
place is incredible,
and it's so different
than what I'm seeing
in New York and San Francisco
and all of those places.
What can Israel export
to the United States
that might help in
our current crisis?
- You know what,
I think the most important
thing is meaning,
a sense of purpose in life,
that there's a reason
to be on this earth.
And we only get, you know, 70,
80, 90 years on this earth.
You want to make it count.
There's a real sense
of purpose here,
that people are
here for a reason.
They're building something.
They're building something
that matters, that counts.
They're bringing back to
life Biblical prophecies.
They're fulfilling, you
know, Judeo-Christian values.
We've grown untethered from
that in the United States.
You know, we don't
have relationships,
interpersonal relationships
like we used to.
People go on dates, you know,
by texting, by WhatsApp-ing.
I mean, everybody's looking
at their phone all day long.
I mean, there's, you know,
they invented the iPhone here,
so it's not like they
don't do it here too.
(Dave laughs)
But it's, there is a sense
that there's something
bigger than ourselves
that's driving us forward.
And I gotta tell you,
when you lose that,
it's a quick trip to the
bottom, it really is.
I mean, you need to have that
sense of meaning and purpose.
And America had that.
America was, you
know, it was the,
for many people, it
was the new Jerusalem.
That's what our founders
thought about it.
They were Christians
who viewed this as the,
you know, as the new Jerusalem,
as the new, you know,
as the shining city on a hill,
as a place of purpose that
would be a light to the nations.
And
we don't teach that anymore.
We don't, people don't
really understand
why America was created,
why it's great.
And,
that is, I think, a
very valuable message
that could come out of Jerusalem
and the whole state of Israel.
- Now I have a request for you
that just popped into my head.
- Sure.
- What do you say we
do this twice a year?
We do it once in Florida
and once in Israel,
and we keep working
this thing out.
What do you think?
- It'd be my pleasure.
- Thank you, Ambassador.
- Thanks, Dave.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about international issues,
check out our
International Playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our Full Episode
Playlist, all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.